voici parrot au delà de ces mignonnes
études se focaliser est aujourd'hui
présente dans 300 établissements
français créé et développé au japon où
il est distribué par une société en
deuxième on va l'utiliser auprès de
différentes populations donc la personne
âgée sur par exemple de la maladie
d'alzheimer et troubles dégénératifs ou
alors même des troubles d'agressivité il
est là pour apaiser pour calmer ou pour
accompagner des soins qui vont être
peut-être un peu douloureux ou des
approches peut-être difficile comme
hymne au 3 mai d'une cinquantaine
d'exposants s'est rassemblé lors de la
5e édition du salon hit onomie
appartements équipés de domotique vente
et location de matériel d'accessibilité
le numérique faut il faire très
attention ça peut être un très bel outil
d'appui mais sait pas ce qui va gérer
réellement l'indépendance parce que la
dépendance ça va aussi bien de la santé
ça va aussi bien dans l'habitat ça va
aussi bien car dans l'immobilité mais la
question est de savoir comment 24 heures
sur 24 on sera en contact permanent avec
les dépendants et c'est toute la
question aujourd'hui de la notion du
matière de missiles en 2015 la france
métropolitaine comptait entre 400 mille
et un million cinq de personnes âgées en
perte d'autonomie vivant à domicile
quand les seniors restent à la maison et
qu'ils sont
rien n'est adapté en fait c'est là où
tout prendre la place le lève malade
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est encombrant
matériel et là c'est vrai qu'il ya des
structures pas en plus lit qui m'ont
tout sonne déjà ça c'est un c'est
quelque chose en moins déjà qui prend
moins de place on va dire on a des
souvenirs ça c'est sûr on a quand même
un habitué à pas mal de choses et faire
un changement il faut bien y réfléchir
c'est toujours intéressant de saintes on
va dire entre guillemets de s'instruire
parce qu'on ne sait jamais de quoi
demain sera fait surtout quand on est
moins jeunes pour les yvelines selon une
étude de l'insee d'ici 2050 le nombre
d'habitants âgés de 75 ans et plus
pourraient atteindre près de deux cent
mille personnes